Speaker 1: by the way. Actually,
speaking of the Republican Civil War,
George W. Bush has maxed out his donations to
two anti-Trump Republicans who supported the
impeachment of Donald Trump. I'm talking about
Liz Cheney, yes, the daughter of Bush's former VP
and Alaska Republican Senator Lisa Murkowski. Now
let me give you the facts first. But don't assume
what I think is important about this story,
because it's not George W. Bush is a good guy.
Business Insider reporting George W. Bush maxes
out political donations to Trump impeachment
supporters. Liz Cheney and Lisa Murkowski OK.
Former President George W. Bush gave the maximum
allowed political contributions to Wyoming
Representative Liz Cheney and Alaska Senator
Lisa Murkowski. Two Republicans who supported
impeaching Trump over the Jan. six Capitol riot.
New disclosures filed with the FEC said Bush gave
Cheney $1800 on October 28th and on December 31st,
he gave Murkowski 29 hundred for her primary. The
FEC sets the limits on political contributions.
The story here is not, and this is a key thing.
The story here is not. Bush is a great guy. We
should elect people like Bush. We should elect
people like Liz Cheney and Lisa Murkowski.
We should rehabilitate George W. Bush's image now
that he's painting and doesn't like Trump. No,
that is not the story, and it's a very unfortunate
thing, and I don't know to what degree they're
cynically doing it and to what degree they're
honestly doing it. There are some on the left
who love to take stories like this one that
I'm doing and say, Look at these faux leftists
who now love Bush, despite him being a disastrous
war criminal and getting us into these two war.
Now the story here is not what a great
guy George W. Bush is. The story here is
the Republican Civil War is maybe the best chance
the Left has to help itself because the left is
increasingly unable to help itself in any other
way. That's all this is. I am not optimistic about
the left in the United States, by which I mean
the most left elements of the Democratic Party,
which at this point is the one even possible
vehicle for the left to do anything in the U.S..
I don't have any confidence that in 2022 and 2024,
Democrats slash leftists are well positioned and
prepared to get anything done. And so I'm hoping
Republicans will help us. That's all this is.
And the more Republicans are divided, the
more potential there is for an opportunity
to defeat them and to prevent them from taking
the House, the Senate, the White House over the
next two election cycles. Let's not forget.
That every single Republican elected official
that supported impeachment is now participating
in the obstruction of of letting Joe Biden do
anything, these are not good people. And even
if they don't like Trump, their obstruction
of Biden may well help Donald Trump get reelected
in three years. So it's OK to recognize Trump was
more incompetent than George W. Bush and still
not like George W. Bush and recognize that Bush
donating to these Republicans might foment the
Republican Civil War to our advantage. We can
do all of these things. We can walk and chew
gum at the same time. At least some of us can.
There is this impulse. By some, maybe to sweep
George W. Bush's disastrous misdeeds under
the rug because he's painting pictures and
showing a cough drop with Michelle Obama and
donating to anti-Trump Republicans. But he was
not a good president. His increase of the powers
of the presidency are probably to some degree
responsible for allowing some of Donald Trump's
worst abuses. When he was president, Bush got us
into some of the longest wars in American history,
one based on a phony intelligence case that he
sent Colin Powell to make. He expanded torture.
We're not praising Bush, and that's that. That's
the end of it. And this is how most people would
behave. You know, when you attack someone's family
or them, the way Donald Trump did to George W.
Bush for years, it's normal that George W.
Bush would say, I'm going to donate to the
people that are against this guy. It's just
totally reasonable. Ted Cruz did the opposite.
Donald Trump called Ted Cruz's wife ugly,
and then Ted Cruz fell in line and said,
Trump's amazing. He's fantastic. He's great. We
love him. We love Trump. Most people wouldn't
do that. Most people would do what George W.
Bush is doing. It doesn't make him a hero,
and it doesn't make him someone we align with
politically. Period, full stop end of story.
Let's follow this Republican civil war and see
to what degree it can be useful to the left
to try to get some wins, or at least prevent
some losses in the next two election cycles.